>>> A GROUP OF SEVEN NATIONS OR
P-7 IS DEMANDING THE
UNCONDITIONAL RELEASE OF THE
OPPOSITIONAL ACTIVIST WHO WAS
DETAINED AFTER THE RYANAIR
FLIGHT WAS FORCED TO LAND IN
BELARUS.
ROMAN PROTOSEVICH'S PARENTS
APPEARED AT A NEWS CONFERENCE
TODAY ALONGSIDE HIS COLLEAGUE,
WIPING AWAY TEARS.
HIS MOTHER SAID IT'S CLEAR HER
SON HAS BEEN BEATEN AND HIS NOSE
BROKEN.
SHE URGED MORE INTERNATIONAL
PRESSURE ON BELARUS.
>> Translator: DEAR JOURNALISTS,
I BEG YOU TO HELP SPREAD IN
INFORMATION TO HELP ME SAVE MY
CHILD, MY SON.
PLEASE HEAR THE SCREAM OF MY
HEART.
IT'S A HORRIBLE SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN.
ALL HE WANTED WAS TO HELP HIS
COUNTRY, HIS FELLOW CITIZENS.
WE ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
>> WELL, THE AVIATION FALLOUT
FROM ALL OF THIS CONTINUES AS
AIRLINES ARE TRYING TO AVOID
BELARUS AIR SPACE.
AIR FRANCE CANCELING THE FLIGHT
YESTERDAY AND AUSTRIA AIRLINES
CANCELED THE FLIGHT FROM VIENNA
TO AUSTRIA.
WELL, THERE'S CONCERN GROWING
FOR ROMAN PROTOSEVICH'S SAFETY
AFTER THE DEATH OF ANOTHER
ACTIVIST.
A DEATH THAT SUGGESTS ABUSE.
CNN'S NICK PATON WALSH HAS OUR
EXCLUSIVE REPORT.
SOME OF YOU MAY FIND THE IMAGES
IN THE REPORT DISTURBING.
>> Reporter: THE PLANE HIJACKING
MAY RAGE AND DAILY ABUSE LOOKS
LIKE THIS.
THIS DODDERING FIGURE IS AN
ACTIVIST.
HE FALLS INTO THE TOILET WITHOUT
ANYONE TOUCHING HIM IN THIS
EDITED SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE,
SUPPLIED BY THE BELARUSIAN
AUTHORITIES WHO ARE EAGER TO
SHOW THEY HELPED THE 50-YEAR-OLD
PRISONER.
BUT HERE, AGAIN, THEY SHOW HIM
BANDAGED AND HE AGAIN SEEMS TOO
WEAK TO STAND.
HIS RELATIVES SAY THEY MET HIM
HEALTHY, BUT THEY WERE INITIALLY
TOLD HE DIED OF A CARDIAC
ARREST.
HERE IS HIS BODY AND AT HIS
FUNERAL, HIS HEAD BANDAGED.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE NATURAL
CAUSES.
OUTSIDE, THEY GATHER, THE FAMILY
BURYING HIM WITHOUT BEING ABLE
TO GET AN INDEPENDENT
EXAMINATION.
THE TRUTH STOLEN FROM THEM, EVEN
IN DEATH.
>> Translator: AS A HUMAN BEING,
I DON'T BELIEVE A MAN'S HEART
JUST STOPPED, THAT HE FELL AND
KILLED HIMSELF.
I REALLY WANT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND IN THESE
CONDITIONS, IT SEEMS IMPOSSIBLE
TO HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
EXAMINATION.
>> Reporter: HE WAS ARRESTED IN
AUGUST, PROTESTING AGAINST THE
FRAUDULENT ELECTIONAL VICTORY
PROCLAIMED AGAINST LUKASHENKO.
THEN HE WAS SENTENCED FOR FIVE
YEARS FOR ALMOST ORGANIZING
PROTESTS.
THE OPPOSITION'S LEADER IN EXILE
CALLED FOR A NEW STAGE IN THE
PROTEST MOVEMENT TODAY, MEETING
WITH EUROPEAN OFFICIALS AND EARL
YEAR EXPRESSED HER ADMIRATION.
>> I ADMIRE HIS FAITH IN
CORRECTNESS OF THE CHOICE BUT
I'M HURT THAT HE PAID WITH HIS
LIFE.
NOW THAT WE HAVE WOKEN UP IT'S
OUR DUTY TO BRING THE MATTER TO
AN END.
>> Reporter: WHEN THE MAN FEARED
FOR HIS LIFE, IT'S -- THESE
SCENES WERE FROM THE POLICE
STATION THAT HE HAD IN MIND.
BRUTALITY IN CUSTODY IS
COMMONPLACE.
DEMONSTRATORS FORCED TO FACE THE
WALL, BEATEN THEY SAID HERE AND
ONE LEFT MOTIONLESS ON THE
FLOOR.
ACTUAL DEATHS HAVE BEEN RARE SO
FAR, THE DEATH PENALTY REMAINS
IN FORCE.
AND THE FATE OF CHIRAC,
SOMETHING THAT THE POLICE WOULD
PASS WITHOUT NOTICE IS HELD UP
AS A WARNI